ah
durante mucho tiempo jordania era
conocida por estos inmensos campos de
refugiados construidos en medio del
desierto y considerados como cárceles al
aire libre actualmente todavía hay
120.000 sirios viviendo en estas
condiciones pero la gran mayoría más de
un millón vive en la ciudad en el norte
de jordania a tan sólo 20 km de la
frontera siria los habitantes de la
ciudad de mafraq se han duplicado desde
el comienzo de la guerra en siria hace
ya 10 años
doscientos ochenta mil refugiados viven
aquí algunos todavía duermen en carpas
pero la mayoría ha construido casas o ha
alquilado apartamentos
con 24 años nayem al hamoud vio nacer
este barrio este sitio era una
adolescente cuando su familia decidió en
2013 huir de los combates en alepo
hace nueve años no estaban todas estas
personas ni todos estos edificios esta
calle se llenó de vida como pueden ver
algunos abrieron supermercados
ferreterías restaurantes farmacias se
volvió el barrio sirio y unos años atrás
nadie vive de pequeños trabajos
cada mes debe conseguir cuatrocientos
euros para alimentar a su familia a
falta de no haber podido estudiar
gracias a una ong el joven recibió una
formación como electricista y una caja
de herramientas cuando uno adquiere el
material hay que pagarlo con el propio
salario y no sobra nada del trabajo que
se hizo hoy nadie va a la casa de un
cliente jordano para verificar el
sistema eléctrico que instaló
hola cómo estás hola
a diferencia de los demás países de la
región aquí la integración de los sirios
es de desarrollo sin muchas tensiones
porque todos comparten un mismo idioma y
además pertenecen a las mismas tribus
presentes en ambos países
las familias están divididas entre los
dos lados de la frontera
tenemos la misma sangre entonces no hay
conflictos
para poder ejercer su nuevo oficio nadie
tuvo un permiso de trabajo hasta hace
poco jordania perseguía el empleo ilegal
de refugiados pero ante la presión de la
comunidad internacional el rey no cambió
sus leyes en 2017 para permitir que los
sirios fueron contratados en varios
sectores como el agrícola la
construcción el hotelero o la industria
esta ong danesa facilita las
formalidades administrativas
como sabes la póliza de seguros te
permite estar cubiertos si tienes un
accidente laboral esta declaración me
permitirá trabajar de manera
completamente legal sin tener problemas
con el empleado de visas y el gobierno
empezó a perseguir a los que no tenían
un permiso y aumentaron los riesgos de
ser detenido por la policía o de ser
enviados de vuelta a los cambios
entonces les interesó tener los papeles
al día
el resultado de esta normalización ha
sido que las zonas industriales cercanas
a la frontera de empleo en muchos sitios
los refugiados se han convertido en la
mano de obra de las fábricas jordanas en
particular en el sector textil
casi que fashion emplea alrededor de 350
cirios esta empresa fundada por indios
se exporta la totalidad de su producción
en eeuu
[Música]
trabajo aquí para ayudarle a mi familia
es difícil encontrar un trabajo siendo
refugiado y todavía más siendo una mujer
contratamos cirios creo que necesitan
trabajo y al mismo tiempo se dedican a
su labor es una alianza donde todos
ganamos ellos reciben un sueldo y
nosotros también ganamos porque contamos
con buenos empleados para nuestra
producción este cambio radical de
política frente a los sirios es el
resultado de una larga negociación entre
la monarquía jordana y los países
occidentales que quieren limitar la
llegada de nuevos refugiados para rne a
sabah periodista de investigación la
integración sea negocio a cambio de
importantes inversiones a cambio del
derecho al trabajo para los sirios los
donantes financiaron las
infraestructuras la educación y demás
con 8 mil 100 millones de dólares su
normal
onetoone familiar pero hasta ahora no se
sabe cómo se gastó ese dinero tiene una
vez más los ventajas para atraer a los
extranjeros ricos el reino pobre en
recursos naturales ahora le saca
provecho a su pasaporte desde 2018 200
emprendedores de los cuales una gran
mayoría son sirios adquirieron la
nacionalidad jordana
la obligación invertir mínimo 620 mil
euros una oportunidad para analizar
jabour a causa de los combates este
originario de damasco desplazó su
empresa de detergentes hacia las afueras
de ammán y esas cajas serán enviadas
hacia 18 países distintos la empresa
empezó con 1500 metros cuadrados y hoy
en día tenemos alrededor de 50.000
metros cuadrados estoy orgulloso porque
empezamos desde cero e hicimos una muy
buena inversión aquí gracias a este
pasaporte nízar jabour puede viajar y
hacer negocios con más facilidad toda su
familia también recibió el beneficio me
siento mucho más seguro por supuesto hoy
en día somos parte de la sociedad
jordana
según las autoridades esta política de
pasaporte a cambio de inversión permitió
crear 7000 empleos y le ha aportado más
de 1000 millones de euros a la economía
del reino unos ingresos muy bien
recibidos ahora que la monarquía entró
en recesión tras la pandemia de covite